hello everyone and welcome to round
number three of the 1970 pomade America
inter-zonal tournament here Bobby
Fischer faces William Edison Bobby has
the white pieces and this is already the
sixth time Bobby faces William Edison so
far they they've played five games Bobby
won three games but the last two games
they played I believe in 64 and 65 were
drawn or maybe 65 66 doesn't really
matter first time the play was in 1958
in the US Open and ever since they've
been meeting up in the United States
championships but as Bobby didn't play
in the 1969 US Championship here you
remember the final standings of the 1969
u.s. championship there we have rochev
ski bonnet with eight points but then
you have Addison in second place with
seven and a half points so definitely a
strong player and it will be very
interesting to see what he comes up here
with the black pieces and the two draws
he achieved against the Bobby were one
with the black pieces and one with the
white pieces so it's very interesting
because in this game Bobby opened with
e4 and his opponent William Addison
played d5 the Scandinavian defense and
it is said that when Bobby saw this if I
move that he there was a big smile on
his face
it is said so in Frank Brady's a profile
of a prodigy of course Fischer
considered Scandinavian to be an
inferior defense for black so naturally
he didn't mind playing against it
ich after Sun d5 which is of course
definitely the best move forcing black
to bring his queen into the game early
Queen captures on d5 and Knight to c3
now developing a piece and forcing black
squint to once again move so the popular
choices are Queen to a5 I myself enjoy
Queen to d6 followed by g6 but the move
that was playing to the game is Queen to
d8 and it's not that this is a mistake
or anything but it's just wasting a lot
of moves with the Queen Bobby played d4
we have Knight to f6 and now Bishop to
c4 and here Karpov says that okay maybe
Bishop to c4 is a move
nowadays play players wouldn't play as
it allows the bush up to g4 Bishop to g4
would have been a very nice move because
it prevents white from achieving rapid
development here if white plays f3 you
can simply go back now the f3 pawn is
preventing this Knight and queen from
bead being developed on f3 and if
instead after Bishop g4 simply Knight G
to E - then black simply continues
developing in the game after Bishop to
c4 Edison played Bishop to f5 which
really allows the Bobby to go for some
insane development here Bobby plays
Queen to f3 attacking the bishop on f5
but also attacking the pawn on b7 so you
pretty much have two choices here you
can either bring the bishop back which
would be silly as you just place them in
f5 or you can play Queen to see it which
defense both threats which was played in
the game and here again when Bobby
played Queen to f3 his c2 coupon was
under attack but of course the black
couldn't take advantage of this because
blacks b7 pawn was under attack here a
fissure yet again offers the C do pawn
he goes for Bishop to g5 and again
really shows how like Murphy who Fischer
holds in the highest regard favours
activity above all Bishop to g5 and now
you really have to capture the C to pawn
or white white really has too much too
much development so ok Bishop captures
on C to rope the c1 forcing the bishop
back
Bishop to g6 and now Knight G to E - so
this is only move 9 in the game Fischer
already has all of his pieces developed
as you can see here he's ready to castle
and if you look at black spawns all of
them are still and second on 7th rank
okay denied and Bishop early in the game
but this is you know black has a long
way to go from having some safety for
his King Knight B to d7 Fischer castles
we have e 6 now and here you could try a
lot of things nice to f4 is definitely a
nice idea piling up on this week is
exponent but Fischer goes for from much
simpler idea he goes for Bishop captures
on f6 and now the point being if you
play Knight captures on f6 then d5
breaks breaks open the position nicely
he captures the knight characters
tonight capture
the show characters you're attacking the
b7 point twice with the bishop and the
Queen after black defends this you can
never capture the bishop as the pawn is
pinned from the rock and c1 Knight to f4
and it's game over for black rook rook
to e1 is coming there's nothing I can do
here
so after this Bishop captures on f6 move
Edison tried G captures on f6 Fischer
nevertheless goes to d5 he wants to
break open the center as the black King
is still in the center of the board
Edison of course it doesn't want to
allow this he closes the position he
plays d5 we have Bishop to b5 now
pinning the night here on d7 Queen
captures on f6 would be a very nice idea
now Bishop to e7 defending perhaps
preparing to castle but it would be very
dangerous to castle here for black
Fischer goes the Knights to g3 the
knight from g3 will be very useful in in
you know getting getting it back into
the game controlling the e4 square
supporting h4 h5 here first
86 was played either trying to get
Fischer to capture the 97 of course
Fischer is not interested in doing
anything like this
Bishop back to d3 and now Queen to d8
there really isn't really a good move
here castling here would be really
dangerous if black castle Bishop to a5
would be very nice now pinning this
knife from this side and black really
doesn't have all that much more say h4
h5 is coming black ever captures her
than the bishop on e7 becomes under
attack queen g4 Queen g7 would be
checkmate a lot of very dangerous ideas
so after Bishop to d3 Queen to d8 was
played
we have h4 now and now to prevent h5
Addison plays h5 himself
Fischer plays Bishop to f5 and now we
have night the b6 and here as you can
see there's a double attack against this
d5 pawn rook F 2 d1 would be pretty much
an automatic by everyone but Fischer
once again favors activity above all he
sees that the d4 d5 pawn is you know
free forget free for grabs he plays the
Knight to e4 again goes for activity
capturing on g6 followed by Knight to f6
would be a nice idea
and black again doesn't have all that
much to do here he grabs the pawn which
is which is a nice idea he wants to play
c6 cemented this pawn on d5
so now Fischer place rook F to d1
attacking the d5 knight c6 defending and
now Fischer's or all of Fischer's pieces
are ideally placed he plays Knight to c3
which is the strongest move and now
there is simply too much pressure
against this d5 Knight black plays Queen
to b6 getting the Queen out of the D
file but it doesn't help now he wanted
to give back some material after Knight
captures pawn captures but Fischer
doesn't go for this he plays the
absolute best move so feel free to pause
the video here and figure out what move
Fischer played you know to put the final
nail in the coffin as they say so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
excellent sacrificer of the exchanges or
you have excellently sacrificed the
exchange we could say and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
Fischer played rook captures on d5 and
now you have to capture the rook
otherwise you're just lost so after pawn
captures Knight captures this comes with
an attack on the Queen in the game Queen
captures on b2 was played but it doesn't
help you all that much to play something
like Queen to d8 here Bishop captures
and g6 is coming now what do you play
after F captures on g6 simply Knights
the system check and black is lost if
you play King f8 96 check the King wins
the Queen if you try something like King
to f7 then you get Queen b3 check again
you lose the Queen only squares
available to you as the knight is
covering both of these cores are the
dark squares f8 and g7 wherever you play
f8 or g7 96 again check the King and
wins the Queen and lastly after Bishop
captures on g6 after you capture and
night to c7 check
you could try instead of going to f7 you
could try King d7 but then you're again
ok you're just getting checkmate at
Queen d5 King moves Knight captures on
a6 opening up our discover check from
the rook the King is cut off from b8
after the Queen blocks ro captures on c7
will be checkmate
so after this night capture Sun d5 queen
capture Sun be to was played because as
Karpov says what else is there
rook to be one now again you could play
97 check pick up the rock but there's no
point in doing this Fischer yet again
favors activity above all Queen captures
on a2 and now row capture some b7 and it
was after this row capture some b7 move
that William Addison resigned the game
why did he resign there's really nothing
to do here there is a double attack
against this Bishop on e7 so there's
really no good way to prevent this the
bishop is also guarding the pawn on f6
so after something like Bishop to d8
which prevents both threats but captors
and g6 is coming if F captures and g6
and now Knight captures on f6 but rook
captures and now not recapturing with
the Queen immediately although this will
win you the game as well first Queen the
C sex with check King moves and now
Queen captures and have sex with check
whatever King does either here or either
here or here Queen to e7 or g7 would be
check me so yeah after this rook to b7
capturing a pawn will emedicine resign
the game and Fischer is now two and a
half out of three
not a bad start in the 1970 Palma de
Majorca inter-zonal tournament
especially for someone who didn't even
qualify to play in this tournament but
yeah that's game number three I do hope
you've enjoyed it and the coverage of
the tournament so far as usual you can
check out my previous videos here thank
all for watching and I will see you with
game number four soon to come thank you
all and see you soon